when we started we've looked at the
winning entry in the tracking challenge
which was essentially a challenge where
the greatest computer vision people
compute to produce the best object
tracker and what we saw was that the
winning track it runs at one frame a
second on an eight code machine in
parallel and to just give a perspective
at cameras frame rates at 30 frames a
second so it was kind of clear to us at
that point that if video analytics was
to take off systems and networking folks
needed to put their heads into the game
and jointly work with the vision
researchers to get a working solution
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger in an
era of unprecedented advances in AI and
machine learning current-gen systems and
networks are being challenged by an
unprecedented level of complexity and
cost
fortunately dr. Ganesha Anantha Narayan
a researcher in the mobility and
networking group at MSR is up for a
challenge and it seems the more
computationally intractable the better a
prolific researcher who's interested in
all aspects of systems and networking
he's on a particular quest to extract
value from live video feeds and develop
killer apps that will have a practical
impact on the world today dr. Anantha
narayan and tells us all about video
analytics for vision zero an
award-winning killer app that aims to
reduce traffic related fatalities to
zero gives us a wide-angle view of his
work in geo distributed data analytics
and client cloud networking and explains
how the duration and difficulty of a
test cricket match provides an
invaluable lesson for success in life
and research that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Ganesh and not the Narayan welcome to
the podcast
thank you thanks for having me yeah I've
heard some people say your last name
could be your secure password I spelled
it wrong once the first year in the US
when I had to file my tax return I added
an extra in in the end and so as a
result the I err is now sent me my
refund useful password if I get it wrong
well and you told me something
interesting about what your name means
yeah the name actually translates to
something like something that never ends
its unending an apt isn't it yeah well
I've got a crazy last name too but as I
said welcome so you work in mobility and
networking here at Microsoft Research
and your work is broadly situated in the
area of systems and networking so we're
gonna do a deeper dive into your current
areas of research shortly but to kick us
off tell us in general what gets you up
in the morning why do we need systems
and networking research and why are you
doing it I mean what gets me up sound
like professionally in the morning is
frankly just a job I have I just love
this job description I have it I can you
know I like creatively explored the
topic that I am interested in keep an
eye out for all the trends that are out
there and at the same time you know work
with this huge sprawling infrastructure
that a company like Microsoft has where
can affect millions of users so to me
that's like the best job description and
that's frankly what gets me excited
everyday systems and networking
specifically I like it because for many
you know suddenly given a very
philosophical level I connect to it
because the core aspects of systems and
networking are a you know there are
trade-offs all the time there's no
single perfect solution which is kind of
true if you think about it in life in
general and the second thing is you know
you cannot hide behind idealized models
success is what works out in the real
world and that's kind of true with you
know life in general and systems and
networking so in many ways I connect
with it
well you know we're gonna go sort of all
over here because you have such a broad
range of interest but you have a big
interest in live video analytics which
we'll get to in a second but I want to
stay upstream for a minute to set the
stage for that and one of the things
that shows up in talks you give is this
phrase cameras are everywhere it's both
reassuring and frightening at the same
time so we'll get to frightening later
in the podcast but for now I want you to
answer two questions why are there
cameras everywhere and why is this a
good thing in many ways I think the
falling camera prices contribute to it
but the main reason I think cameras are
seeing this pervasive deployment is the
fact that there is this ability for you
to monitor things to record things and
many ways I think people who put these
cameras in there and sort of like the
early stages with the hope that there
would be a human who is going to look at
it and perhaps react to certain things
and so forth and as we saw this
potential with what you know computer
vision could do but hey I could actually
analyze these cameras in real time
perhaps if needed this camera streams
and do a bunch of good stuff with it so
that was kind of what we went with in
terms of saying hey what are the kind of
things that we can enable with these
cameras that frankly can be very
beneficial to us as a whole I can give
an example of her like a recent demo
that we did at the Microsoft tech fest
we demoed like a smart crosswalk but if
say somebody with special needs comes to
the edge of the crosswalk say in a
wheelchair then we would detect that
automatically and then have the walk
light turned on for them and not only
that what we also do is that as the
person is crossing if he noticed that
hey the timer is going to go off but
that this person at the pace at which
they're walking needs some additional
time to finish crossing safely you give
like an additional say 10 seconds or so
so that they can finish crossing so so I
see a lot of potential for a lot of good
that can come out of just doing this
video analytics and that can happen only
if cameras are everywhere
I'm thinking of all the places that I
know there are cameras like convenience
stores traffic light cameras traffic
cameras in general on the highways
retail scenarios and then we go back to
this idea that somebody should be able
to take those images and do something
usually after the fact right when did it
become so overwhelming that we needed
computers in the mix so in both cases I
think even for after the fact if we have
to search through months of videos there
is like a rate at which you can process
it if a human is viewing it maybe we can
wield that 2x2 speed but that still
would take a lot of time if I am viewing
2 months worth of video and then of
course then there's additional point
where hey why should we stop at only
doing things after the fact like the
crosswalk scenario I just explained that
can happen only if we analyze the feeds
in real time right so that's when I
think we started getting into this thing
where hey we need to actually analyze
these feeds in real time live video
analytics talk about the challenges that
you face once you have the aha moment to
be able to technically accomplish that
so live video analytics is very
challenging from a systems and
networking perspective as we see it is
you know among the various domains for
say systems built for AI this was the
most challenging because you know the
amount of compute that is needed the
amount of data that is generated the
amount of storage that is needed the
kind of privacy concerns that come out
of videos these are all nothing like any
other domain and if you look at you know
what I listed in terms of compute the
network the storage the security and
privacy these are all the major pillars
of systems and networking and video and
Linux stresses each one of them so from
that point of view we thought it was a
pretty you know interesting challenge to
take on and then what we also noticed
was that you know obviously we got
excited to doing video analytics because
we saw the possibilities of what
computer vision could achieve but when
we started looking at the actual
solutions
we also notice that hey many of these
solutions that are kind of cool to
require an enormous amount of resources
for it to run that it's almost
impractical if you were to run something
like this 24/7 right just to give a
concrete example you know when we
started we've looked at the winning
entry in the tracking challenge which
was essentially a challenge where the
greatest computer vision people compute
to produce the best object tracker and
what we saw was that the winning tracker
runs at one frame a second on an eight
code machine in parallel this is for a
single camera and to just give a
perspective at cameras frame rates at 30
frames a second so it was kind of clear
to us at that point that if video
analytics was to take off systems and
networking folks needed to put their
heads into the game and jointly work
with the vision researchers to get a
working solution okay so let's say
you've linked arms now what is your
quest what are you trying to accomplish
in this field so what we are primarily
ought to do is to democratize video
analytics which is sort of being able to
analyze videos live in real time at low
cost and at the same time produce
results that are accurate enough for the
task at hand how's that going it's going
pretty good we've been at it for a
couple of years now we've had many
systemic breakthroughs in terms of how
we could make things substantially
cheaper we've engaged with a bunch of
customers in terms of analysing their
needs and so forth so I think we have
like a good sense for what it is that
people want with video analytics so I
would say we're quite excited in terms
of how its progress so far and the road
ahead all right well we're gonna get on
that road pretty quick here it does make
me laugh however to note that what
you're aiming for is cheap fast and good
we're all looking for that Holy Trinity
of cheap fast and good usually they say
pick two right if you want it cheap and
fast it's not gonna be good trying to
cheap and good it's not gonna be fast
and video analytics it's like the uber
challenge it's actually true I've caught
this point actually in my talks to that
in there's gold
of all the three axes I usually said if
you think about it
achieving any two of the three is much
easier than aiming for all three so
totally agree with you so you've given
yourself like the hardest task is the
hardest I mean we also looking at it and
if you look at say the whole space of
Internet of Things right cameras are the
hardest of things so yeah I think if we
get this right then we should be able to
you know navigate through a whole bunch
of other verticals as well in this space
so exciting
[Music]
well let's get specific and I want to
focus this part of our conversation
around your work in healthcare okay I'm
making air quotes around that okay
because you're not doing healthcare but
and I didn't know this before I talk to
you traffic accidents are among the top
ten leading causes of death in the world
and all the others that surrounded our
actually healthcare issues so you've got
a hero app for that you call it video
analytics for vision zero tell us about
it
yes you're right it kind of shocked us
as well to hear that traffic generated
fatalities we're among the top ten
reasons for deaths worldwide so when we
started out this project on video
analytics we wanted to really have like
a driving application where this was
really useful so at that point we
reached out to the city of Bellevue
where we wanted to check if we could
utilize their traffic cameras for any
kind of analysis that they would want to
do and he had so happened that the city
of Bellevue had signed on to this
program called vision zero vision zero
was a larger initiative that started in
the late 90s in Sweden where the idea
was to get the number of traffic related
fatalities to zero and so the city of
Bellevue was interested in partnering
with us and we had like a very
forward-looking and enthusiastic partner
in France LuAnn Hertz in the City of
Bellevue and along with France the
question that we asked was how can we
use these cameras to improve traffic
safety traffic efficiency and just
long-term planning of traffic so we
worked with the city of Bellevue in
terms of analyzing their live feeds to
produce you know live traffic counts to
raise alerts when the amount of traffic
is abnormally high or low we've helped
them in terms of a bike planning
initiative that they had where we want
to do like a before after study on how
the number of cars and the number of
bicycles changed yeah so overall this
has been an initiative that in many ways
has been sound like trend-setting we've
presented this work at a lot of
transportation engineering forums and
many cities have expressed interest in
terms of adopting a solution like this
so in many ways we believe we've opened
the eyes of folks to what is possible
with video analytics in the space of
traffic cameras so that's been pretty
good yeah let's get a little more
technical here since we're talking about
cars let's look under the hood a video
analytics for vision zero and talk about
rocket which is the aptly named video
analytics engine behind it so break down
the technical components of rocket and
explain how this approach is bringing
some of those traditional barriers to
accurate and affordable video analytics
to real people rocket I think we had
like a poster title once it's a rocket
to enable video analytics to take off so
the rocket stack has many components and
it right at the top of this stack is
this ability to express video analytics
as a pipeline of various operators so we
needed those abstractions where somebody
can look at it and go okay what is the
set of operations that I should string
together for me to run this video
analytics application specifically an
example of that could be take the video
stream run a decoder maybe run a filter
where some of the frames can be filtered
off then you run an object detector and
say then a classifier and then you of
course in the end you have some custom
logic say for counting and so forth
so this is what sits right at the top of
the rocket stack this this pipeline
expression and then we have the pipeline
optimizer which is kind of important
because what I explained right now is an
example of a generic pipeline different
choices have to be made for different
pipelines depending on what the camera
stream looks like right what is the kind
of filter that I should use that's best
for this specific camera stream what's
the kind of object detector that suits
the best what's the frame rate at which
I could be running it like for instance
if this is a stream where say it's at
night there's not that much activity
happening now I can sample out a lot of
frames and I can save on resources as if
it's in the daytime I don't want to be
sampling frames off too much this is
kind of what the optimizer makes a
decision on which is what kind of
configurations should we be picking for
this specific camera and then after this
comes the resource manager where it
looks at not just one specific pipeline
but say a bunch of you know pipelines
together presumably a city has hundreds
of cameras and all of them are alike
running together in a cluster so to
speak so if I have these resources how
is it that I would distribute these
resources across these different
pipelines clearly I want to be giving
resources to those pipelines that need
the most to get the sufficient amount of
accuracy that they need so this is kind
of what the resource manager does and
once this is done we move to an
important portion of the project where
video analytics intersects with edge
computing where we are not going to be
doing video analytics especially at
scale if all the videos have to come to
a single central place in the cloud so
video analytics has to be split across a
bunch of smart cameras some edge
clusters in between and then the cloud
so after the resource manager does its
thing we move on to this edge cloud
executor that splits these video
analytics pipelines between the various
edge clusters and the cloud and finally
what we do is heavy running live video
analytics already can
use the results from this to just index
the times when say a car showed up when
an accident happened or a near accident
happened store them so that later on if
you ask me a query on say in the last
month last two months can you find me
the times when there were accidents
you don't have to process the entire set
of videos at the time you're asking the
query you should just be able to pull it
off an index so this way we can actually
answer queries and even store videos
like almost like three orders of
magnitude faster than otherwise all
right so you've partnered with say the
City of Bellevue and it's actually was
it a research project or have you
implemented this or deployed this
anytime anyplace we've actually
implemented deployed it and had it
running for a long time so we went
through this entire thing where we built
the system we produced say live counts
alerts and a whole bunch of stats for
the traffic we built a dashboard that
displayed all these counts live in real
time including alerts and then this
dashboard running live in the city of
Bellevue traffic management center and
so yeah we wanted to do this entire
thing where we went beyond just you know
saying hey this is the part that I am
interested in yeah instead looking at it
holistically like what does it take to
build the end-to-end
product if you would for something like
this well right about now I want to tell
our listeners that they ought to go to
the website and look under your name
there are talks there are videos there
are projects and papers all about this
it's a very visual thing that you're
doing and there's a lot of video on
there that people can see this in action
it's really cool I looked at it in fact
when I was looking at the vision zero in
Bellevue I was actually looking for my
own car had they caught me the cool
things to do sometimes when I Drive
around with friends is so one of the
cameras we analyze is right next to
Lincoln Square
yeah in Bellevue and it's cool to point
them to that camera and say hey that's
you know one of the cameras that we are
analyzing so so smile smiles we just on
camera yeah all right well let's talk
about some of the other cool
work you're doing one of the attributes
of next-gen data analytics is that
workloads are no longer confined to one
data center but spread out across many
data centers and edge clusters around
the world and this poses a host of
challenges for systems and networking
researchers so tell us about the
challenges and how you're tackling them
through your work on geo distributed
data analytics so my background during
my PhD sent a lot on big data analytics
we did some of the earliest work in
terms of straggling mitigation in big
data analytics which is kind of
important to you know maintain a whole
bunch of service level objectives for
these big data jobs yeah and after that
we're starting to think like you know
what is like the next generation of data
analytics going to look like and we saw
that hey these companies like Microsoft
you know the actual infrastructure is
sprawling it's not just a single data
center but spread out worldwide and
these are not just data centers where a
whole bunch of other edge clusters and
so forth
in many ways you know what we figured
was that hey analyzing all this data
that is so like geo distributed now is
the next sort of like frontier if you
would for big data analytics and so what
we started like ended up with was two
key results or accomplishments first was
that we needed to do these data
analytics without necessarily
aggregating all the data to a single
place because if you were to aggregate
all the data to a single place the
network would be too much of a
bottleneck and that's not the way we
should be doing it and the second thing
we wanted to do was to make sure that
queries and the whole intersection that
we ran in a single data center should
automatically cross over when you run it
across a cluster of data centers as well
so we had this abstraction of sort of
like an Internet spanning cluster again
of all these different you know data
centers and each clusters worldwide and
so then we designed a bunch of solutions
that essentially dealt with the enormous
heterogeneity that you would see in
these different clusters that different
network uplinks and
link's but the cool thing was that you
could write the same query and it will
run both in a single data center as well
as distributed across many data centers
and each clusters and this in many ways
this work the way we're thinking about
it was what's also you know to me
personally led to this topic of video
analytics because I was thinking more
and more about it and it started
becoming clear to me that one of the
biggest sources of distributed data
that's generated is going to be cameras
how is it that you're gonna analyze all
these cameras shames without bringing it
all to a single data center alright
moving on my life is literally dependent
on the rather tenuous idea that all my
technologies are going to get along with
each other all the time
of course everything doesn't always go
perfectly things go wrong and that's why
there's people like you to work on those
systems and networking problems that we
face and as we talked earlier it's like
I don't even often know who to call
anymore is it Amazon is it Comcast is
that Microsoft is it AT&T is it you know
my internet host I don't know so talk
about your work in wide area networking
and how it might help all of us
especially as we depend on our network
to technologies in an increasingly
mission-critical world sure so I focus
on this wide area part of the network or
more specifically the part of the
network that's between the client and
the cloud and I especially see that with
the enormous amount of work that's
happened almost like in the last decade
in terms of the networking inside a data
center and say connecting our own data
centers that the client cloud part is
the weakest link and that's kind of what
we really need to address and take care
of ok and it's kind of interesting you
also brought up this thing about you
know whom to call because one of the
projects that we are actually working
with right now with Azure networking is
this problem where when connectivity is
bad between our clients to any of our
data centers who is the culprit whom to
be blamed we actually call the project
blame it so if you think about it
between the client and us and a bunch of
autonomous systems or a SS in between
and Internet is design
for these autonomous systems to function
autonomously so it's kind of an
interesting challenging problem in terms
of how is it that weeds own in without
necessarily owning all the pieces
between us and the client so this is
work that we've been doing with as your
networking if deployed initial parts of
it and so yeah we excited about where it
can progress okay so without sort of
signing an NDA tell me what you're doing
technically how are you Pru employing
machine learning and AI techniques to
because this is something no human not
even a bunch of humans that have brains
like yours could do so in frame is
interesting since you brought up machine
learning is the way we got interested in
this was that a couple of years back we
are working with the skype team in terms
of relating Skype calls say the caller's
say is in Seattle the colleague is
somewhere in India in Bangalore they
could get into the relays say in
Bellevue go through the Microsoft
backbone and then exit at some point
close to the colleague and so it was
sort of like a problem about which parts
to choose and many ways we map this to a
multi-armed bandit formulation
interesting where we could sort of like
explore all the parts that are out there
for their different performance
characteristics and then exploit the one
that is the best and continuously do it
well while we're on that subject of
machine learning and systems and
networking let's talk a little bit about
your split personality at least part of
you is a networking researcher but the
other part of you is interested in
machine learning techniques and so on so
how do you bring yourselves together and
how does this inform the future of
networking research I primarily see
myself as a systems and networking
person that's kind of what my training
is being a bunch of my work has been in
as well so what I do is bring the
systems and networking lens to a bunch
of other problems like specifically
these days with vision and ml where how
is it that you can make something more
accessible and easy how is it that you
can make some
more cheap how is it that you could make
it more reliable so that helps where we
could get like this bunch of trade-offs
that I had to mention in our
conversation for video analytics for
instance and so that's the direction I
come from but there is also this other
direction which is often kind of useful
too which is a whole lot of problems
that are there in the systems and
networking space could actually benefit
if you can take a look at it from an AI
lens or an ml lens right I had mentioned
about the bandit formulation and this is
a settling a long-standing problem at
houses that you choose the best path
between you know two hosts on the
internet I remember we had a panel at
the Microsoft faculty summit last year
where we hosted a bunch of people on
this topic I think if I recall right the
topic of the panel was the good bad and
the ugly of ml in network systems so we
were debating about the set of topics
where ml is appropriate in a networking
context and I recall one of the points
that we had discussed was that it's good
to have it in cases where it's
computationally intractable like say
scheduling or query planning and I
remember we also had an azure person on
the panel and his point was also that we
also need to get to a point where the
results are explainable because if
something breaks in production the last
thing I want here is that hey I don't
know why this happened so yeah but you
know a bunch of people have already
shown the potential of applying ml to
systems and but I think is the journey
ahead and the possibility that is quite
exciting of what we can apply and do
all right well we've reached the point
in the podcast where I asked what could
possibly go wrong and I think we have to
go back to the phrase cameras are
everywhere we've talked about the upside
and how you're working on applications
that help people and I think we can all
see the benefits there but as we know
with every powerful technology there's
always a downside and some people would
argue that you're creating or if not
creating equipping Big Brother so is
there anything about your work that
keeps you up at night Ganesh this
definitely keeps me up at night in that
hey by making video analytics cheaper is
it the V enabling more and more people
to be surveilled so I look at this from
the paradigm of mechanism and policy
well I see what I'm doing as mechanisms
for doing something and then there is a
whole set of policies that sort of like
explain and stipulate what can be done
and what cannot be done
and so it's heartening to me that this
debate around policy has in many ways
already begin people are already taking
it quite seriously
you know like for instance we tried to
work with the Microsoft surveillance
system and while on one hand it was
frustrating we could not get access to
those feeds and the other hand it made
me feel good about the fact that
somebody is taking it very seriously had
even with Microsoft employees these are
not videos that would just be a love to
you know research yes I think more work
needs to be done on that but I think
we're thinking about it the right way in
terms of saying what is OK to be done
and what is not okay to be done so how
do you deal with the fact that you've
got these raw feeds that I would presume
has all the information on they're not
doing little bars across the eyes while
the cameras rolling and this touches to
this point about edge computing each
computing gives this powerful mechanism
to do these controls as long as the
video is being processed
at your edge it is not leaving your
premises as such so that's a great place
where the raw video can come in you can
say for instance obscura first gave any
sort of sensitive information and then
re encode it and send it out so that
whatever goes out already has a bunch of
these PII sits tripped out PII
personally identifiable information once
they are out and what we have in the
cloud is much less sensitive if you
would and then of course on top of it if
you add policies in terms of what you
can do and cannot do and then I think
yeah we have designed something that's
not necessarily going to enable big
brother but enable things that we think
are constructive and useful to society
all right one of the works that we're
doing right now actually is using secure
enclaves for video analytics even in the
cloud so that the only person who would
know what's happening inside is the
person that's actually running it even
the cloud operator all the operating
system would not be able to immediately
snoop into what's happening well it's
story time Ganesh and again you have a
rather entertaining one tell us a bit
about yourself what got you interested
in systems and networking research where
did you start and how did you end up
here at Microsoft Research I dabbled in
a few things during my undergrad like
anybody would in terms of saying what is
it that really interested me and you
know it kind of got to this conclusion
where the end of my undergrad I thought
hey I wanted to do systems and
networking that it was of course in a
broad sense and so in the place I did my
undergrad we had this requirement where
the last full semester we had to do an
internship and so the forms that you
fill in I had filled in MS R&D it was
just called Microsoft R&D in Bangalore
and I was kind of excited because I
thought hey okay so this is a lab that
I've heard of you know some of my
friends had intern in Microsoft research
during their undergrad like okay so this
sounds good and you know I should give
me a chance to try out things but that
didn't exactly go as expected after I
landed
I realized that this was actually a
global Technical Support Center this was
well it's a hugely important that's
jolly as I said not expected in terms of
what I wanted to do right but the same
thing I also figured that you know dr.
Anand then who is then the head of the
MSR India lab he had just opened the lab
then and I saw his press conferences and
so forth and so what I did was I found
where his office was and I went over to
his office and as the way he puts it
you know I hired myself and that I
essentially told him that Haven would
like to try my hand at research you know
can you give us a chance at it and that
turned out to be pretty good I remember
at that point he said okay come on in
and we started working with him and his
team that was kind of cool and so at
that point on you know I personally also
decided why don't I spend you know a
little more time at this place after my
internship ended and so yeah that got me
interested in systems and networking
then I went to Berkeley for my PhD and
then here in Redmond tell us one thing
about yourself something interesting a
characteristic a life event to trade a
personal work in the interest of yours
that we might not know about you and how
it has influenced your career as a
researcher I can relate to the game of
cricket and there is a form of cricket
called
Test cricket and believe it or not it's
for five days so it's a really long game
or a sport if you would and the game as
such is split you know over five days
each day has three sessions and usually
the lesson I took away from cricket was
that if you want to win the entire Test
match that you don't formulate every
session in a win-lose manner in that you
know at the end of each session just
make sure you building up towards
winning the match but don't take any of
the short term things to you know
seriously more than a positive sends out
a negative sense because interest
that doesn't eventually lead to you
winning the match you win the match if
you keep the eye on the ball for the
entire five days so yeah it helps me
kind of in many ways balance between
what they do short-term what happens in
the short-term both positive and
negative but I always make sure I try to
think for what it is in the long-term or
the test match if you would yeah so
research as Test match research as a
cricket Test match yeah well at the end
of every podcast I give my guests a
chance to say anything they want to our
listeners some of whom might just be
getting their feet wet in systems and
networking research so it could be
something helpful inspirational
cautionary encouraging profound whatever
you get the last word what would you
want to say to people that are getting
their feet wet in systems and networking
I can pass on the lessons that I've
learned from the many illustrious people
I have worked with it's always important
when you choose a problem to look at
something that is relevant ask what's
the impact whose life is it going to
make better and often you know I've seen
that in cases when I have done it that
things turn out to be much better than
the cases when I have not done it so
that's a very handy thing to have as a
question while designing a solution
something I always try to do is try to
keep the solutions simple do not
complicate the solution there is no
great heroism in having a complicated
solution simple is always better and
seek out collaborators there is no
better way to amplify your work they
have a huge multiplying effect and you
have good collaborators so yeah said
that's what I would tell to anyone who
is starting out Occam's razor with a
great team yeah yeah Ganesh Ananta
Narayan and thank you for joining us on
the podcast today thanks for having me
over
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Keynesian
Anthony Ryman and the latest in systems
networking and mobility research visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]
[Laughter]